[Applause]
our next young speaker needs no
introduction but that didn't stop him
from writing one and making me
read it fun fact
i hear you the word valedictorian is
from the latin validisari meaning to say
farewell it is primarily used in the
united states
canada the philippines and armenia
maybe that facts more fun in armenia
please welcome
your valedictorian sheldon cooper
hello i'm not very comfortable speaking
in front of crowds
but there's a technique to reduce stage
fright by focusing on one person in the
audience
and delivering your speech just to them
that's what i'll be doing today
if it weren't for this person i wouldn't
be here right now
they've taught me a lot and it's by
their example that i found the courage
to move forward into this new and
exciting chapter of my life
missy
this is for you
change can be scary but i know we're
going to be fine
because like you said it's okay to be
scared
we just have to do it anyway
so if any of my fellow graduates are
nervous about the future
know that you're not alone i suggest you
all try to be as brave as my twin sister
that's my plan missy
i wish i could give you advice about
middle school but i was so smart i
skipped it
if you make it to high school we'll talk
thank you
the following day i attended my sister's
elementary school graduation
she didn't deliver a speech to me but
she did make eye contact while she sang
this land is your land
[Music]
later that day we had a graduation party
for me and my sister
i don't normally care for parties but
this one wasn't so bad
who's ready for cake me
hey should we say grace heck yeah
let's hold hands oh cool let's say grace
dale invited jesus to the party and
while he wasn't on my guest list
it was okay because it made my mom happy
in fact it was the best graduation party
i had ever been to
until the one we had for my son leonard
cooper
amen i wanted his name to be leonard
nimoy cooper but
amy wouldn't let me be happy i let you
name him leonard
okay okay love you guys
[Music]
foreign